okay so I'm mic drop boom I'm a data
engineer at Mozilla and today I'm going
to talk about a project we're working on
there called iodide and a sub project of
that called Piatt died this is the rough
agenda we'll talk about iodide then and
tell you what piight is and then the
iodide server and how that relates to
everything and then if you stay all the
way to the end of the talk we have a
very fun little toy demo this is our
team we've got five people at Mozilla
and then we have some outside
contributors at academia and in industry
we want to grow this slide with people
here hopefully okay so what is iodide
came out of a problem we had sort of
internally at Mozilla where data
scientists were doing experiments in
order to answer some business question
or some technical question about Firefox
and they would share that with their
manager who makes the decisions the
decision would be made and then all that
stuff would just fall off a cliff and
then you repeat right so there's sort of
this broken cycle things get built
explained and then thrown away where it
would be much nicer to have a cycle that
that sort of connects all of the
different phases of data science the
exploration explanation and
collaboration and keeps it going all in
one system without any friction between
these things this sort of diagram is is
not my own it's shamelessly stolen from
a paper by Adam rule and others called
exploration and explanation in
computational notebooks and one of the
interesting insights in that paper is
that many analysts simply choose to
explain and share their analyses using
other more established media and provide
a link for the curious back to the
notebook where they perform the analysis
in the first place so clearly the the
tool is not supporting all of the things
they need to do or it's making it too
hard to do all the things they need to
do in one tool so we're trying to build
something that's a little more akin to
that so what's the primary difference
between our tool and something like
Jupiter let me be clear right upfront
we're not trying to replace Jupiter
we're exploring a different sort of
trade-off space
right trying to make something that's
different and explore what happens if
you have a different set of trade-offs
what does that help what does that hurt
so on the left this is a diagram stolen
from the Jupiter documentation you may
all be familiar here you have a
graphical user interface in your browser
it communicates to a server that server
commute communicates with a kernel and
that's where the actual data science
computation happens and the kernel is
usually connected to some remote data
source or maybe a local data source
right so that's what you may know what
we've done in ayodhya is we've moved the
kernel into the browser so all of the
computation is happening in the browser
it puts you right next to the UI it
means you can do very interactive low
latency kinds of things with the UI in
the browser and then we do have a server
to allow things like collaboration data
archiving other things but it's totally
optional I think it it's going to be
very important because it sports a lot
of use cases but it's not critical in
order to run an iodine notebook so when
you have these two different models what
you get with Jupiter that you probably
familiar with if you want to share
Jupiter a notebook with someone remotely
state-of-the-art is to deploy it in
container using docker or something and
using binder
this stuff is all way better than it was
a few years ago but it's still a cost
right because you're running a remote
service on someone else's behalf there's
free services to do that they don't
always scale if you're doing it
internally that's a big cost to your IT
infrastructure right and if you're going
to share a notebook locally that person
you're sharing it with it's gonna have
to go to install anaconda install
Jupiter all the dependencies there's a
lot of computation there sorry can't be
complication there the iodine model is
you basically if you want to share
something with someone you put it up on
a static web server every Enterprise
I've ever come across is running a
static web web server somewhere that's a
pretty low cost thing to do and if you
want to just give someone the file you
can do that and they just open up in
their web browser
now obviously the downsides here is your
data's got to be pretty small your
computations got to be pretty simple
but if that's okay with you we're in
this different trade-off space and I
think it creates some interesting
opportunities another major design
feature of what we built is this thing
called jsm d which is shamelessly stolen
from things like MATLAB cell mode or our
markdown the joopa text project is also
going in this direction which is rather
than using JSON like Jupiter notebooks
use we're using a plain text format so
this lets you put it in get get pull
requests work all that tooling around
standard text files works really well
many of our users we found actually they
don't like to use the cells in the
notebook they just open these things up
in their text editor of choice and it
all just works okay so I'm going to do a
quick demo of that this is what a an
iodide notebook looks like it's
communication first this looks like a
blog post or a document write as this
explicative text you can put math in
there and then generally you'd have
something interactive and interactive
visualization here we have a Lorenz
attractor demo all the computation is
here here is happening in the browser I
can change some of the parameters and
all this is very low latency because
there's no server it's going to it's all
happening right here but then beyond
just this acting like a blog post
there's this Explorer button name up
here I push this it's like view source
if you remember the old days of the web
in 90s with Geo cities and what-have-you
you could view source on things and you
could actually look that was how you
learned how to put new things on the web
we're trying to bring that sort of ethos
into the data science world and into the
modern age so here you can see on the
Left there's a this is the code it's in
cells there's markdown with JavaScript
I'm gonna get to the JavaScript issue in
a sec but this is basically all the
things that created the page on the
right hand side we have a console that
behaves very much like Firefox dev tools
you can look at the value of variables
and and play around here and
inspect things and see what they are all
these little tabs kind of move around it
has like a little layout engine and
stuff so anyway it's this neat little
environment development environment so
the idea is you you might come across a
notebook on the web it does something
almost what you want to do or you want
to drill down on the data in somewhere
you would hit the explore button Bob's
your uncle you have a full development
vironment here you just keep going all
right so I'm gonna pop back to my slides
so everything I've talked about so far
is because we're in the browser it's
based built around JavaScript right
javascript has a real love/hate
relationship for me personally I mean on
the one hand it's really fast
it's got probably the best compiler
technology of any dynamic language out
there you can write things it's in a lot
of cases as fast as what you would write
and see that's great on the other hand
you have these really legacy rough edges
the numerix and javascript aren't great
the typing isn't great like a lot of
things you have to learn not to touch in
JavaScript and you do okay if you learn
what not to do it's familiar to a lot of
programmers so the the body of
JavaScript programmers is huge but it's
not very familiar in this crowd right to
data scientists there are some there are
data sciences who use JavaScript but
it's not the big mature ecosystem like
Python has or R has or Julia even right
so that led us to the creation of the PI
that project Piatt died is basically a
compilation of standard upstream C
Python with none by pandas matplotlib
other data science tools to webassembly
now webassembly if you're not familiar
with it it's a fairly new technology in
browsers it's a bit code for compiled
code that you share on the web in your
browser so it's a completely portable
but once it hits your browser it gets
compiled into native code and it runs
really really fast there is some related
projects here this is the first project
I'm aware of that really is data science
focused and tries to get the data
science stack working really well but
there's a pie
hi Jas that brings pie pie into this
environment has the same pros and cons
that pie pie ass right there was zero
dependency Python which was an attempt
to do this with Google Native Client
Google Native Client has sort of been
subsumed to by webassembly it's
basically dead so and then there's
bright on which does something different
it actually trans piles Python into
JavaScript and then runs it so it's not
a proper upstream C Python you wouldn't
get numpy you wouldn't get those other
things so I will pop over again and give
you a demo here I have an iodide
notebook and all you have to do to use
Python we have a little cell type
drop-down here you can say JavaScript or
Python change it to Python run this cell
and over here on the right you see it
says loading the Python plug-in and
second or two later you have a full
Python on let me I'll make this a little
bit bigger I think there we go
and what's really cool here is all the
datatypes sort of automatically convert
back and forth so if I have this Python
data structure and I return it to
display it it's getting converted to
JavaScript and then the iodide tool here
is just displaying it as if it's
JavaScript it doesn't actually know
anything about Python but it's able to
convert is able to display these things
because it's converting the data types
you actually have access to the entire
Dom API of the browser from Python which
is really powerful so here I have a
little cell in Python that's going to
make a little button and a little div
and when I click on the button it'll
increment the value right so there's a
little callback going into Python adding
to the number coming back it all kind of
magically works you could use this to
like rewrite Facebook entirely in Python
if you wanted to I don't recommend that
but you you you literally have
everything there's no shortcoming here
you know another fun little demo you can
do is you can take make a canvas and hit
hook up all the mouse events to like
draw on the canvas and that's all
happening from Python this is also the
basis for how we get matplotlib to work
which I'll show in a sec
so that's all pure Python I've showed so
far if you import numpy it's gonna go
out to the network
fetch numpy bring it down and then it
displays the numbers so I just made a
little sine wave here right it's not not
great to see a sine wave as numbers what
you want to do is plot it right so the
cell import matplotlib it's going out
importing matplotlib all of my plot libs
dependencies it's going out over the
internet from what's currently hosted on
github pages but yeah just from a from
an HTTP website and once you've actually
done this i'm for demo i want it
actually you to see the time but once
this happens once it gets cached in your
browser and it's just really zippy the
next time exactly yeah exactly
and so when you oh here we go
got scroll down so here's matplotlib let
me make this the screen is a little
small here but basically you have a full
matplotlib plot here of the sine wave
and it's fully interactive so all of
this back and forth is happening without
a round-trip to a server right all
entirely within the browser and so
that's really cool you've got like the
the bones of the Python scientific stack
here however because you the data is
actually shared back and forth between
Python without even copying it if you
want you can mix and match things so I
can take this numpy array I've made and
import plotly which is a JavaScript
plotting library and plot it in plotly
so if you prefer plotly it's nothing
keeping you from from using that instead
and it works just as well this of course
is interactive too but here they've
written the plotting library in
JavaScript so it's very tightly coupled
I think that's sort of one of the
coolest parts about this so I will pop
back to my slides
biggest question I get how fast is it
this is a set of sort of numpy numeric
benchmarks that someone else wrote and
you see some variation there the the
scale here is how many times slower it
is in the browser versus native on the
same machine so worst case it gets to be
about ten times in Firefox Chrome is
still significantly slower hopefully
they assume they will catch up at some
point but they are playing some catch up
and the the thing that seems to make the
difference between the things that are
like 10 times slower and the things that
are the same speed is how much Python
work you're doing one thing that is slow
in web assembly is calling a function
pointer and that's for security reasons
which I don't even fully understand to
explain but they've made they have a
little extra work they have to do to
call a function pointer and because the
Python interpreter is basically a
function caller a function pointer
calling machine that's what it does the
more Python stuff you do the slower it
gets
however these these benchmarks down here
they're mainly working in numpy and so
they're like tight see loops they pretty
much herp at par so that's pretty cool
what doesn't work is actually pretty
obvious that the Python test suite is
running and for the most part is working
just great but things that you can't do
in a browser you can't do with this
either so you can't open up over wrong
networks are cut socket and start
serving things over it
you can't for kasib process because we
don't have sub processes in the browser
and you can't access files on your
filesystem right threads and
asynchronous stuff are coming that's not
in webassembly MVP level but there are
plans to build that so eventually
someday we'll get multi-threading in
this you can use web workers now and do
some settings but that's there you're
building specifically for the browser
and it's hard so where do we want this
to go in the immediate future these are
the packages we have we have Python and
numpy and pandas and matplotlib if you
go down the list of the most popular
scientific Python packages the next on
the list or
suck it image and scikit-learn but those
both depend on Syfy and Syfy depends on
Fortran and we it's a little dirty
secret of this community that we're
relying on software using one of the
oldest extant programming languages
around okay so the the story of
compiling Fortran to webassembly isn't
really fully there yet it's not good
enough to compile SCI PI so we're gonna
have to push on that and move that
forward
but once we solve that hopefully we can
also get our so a big part of where we
want to go with this is have having this
nice tightly integrated system where you
can do some of your stats in R where
it's really good and do some of your
data munging in Python where it's really
good and not really care and do that all
in the same process within the browser
the key around that of course is
something like Apache arrow or live nd
type in the middle as the sort of
conversion layer to help you move those
data types around without any copying
but already we have a few other
languages not just Python for outside
contributors have given us Ruby Oh camel
Lua these JavaScript related languages
are obviously really really easy so we
have JSX from react and typescript so
it's growing already into kind of an
ecosystem here the other thing we want
to do is extend Conda Forge
so right now Conda Forge builds for
Linux Mac and Windows we're gonna add a
fourth one called web assembly and that
will hopefully make it a lot easier to
get new packages into this thing and it
won't be a bottleneck on a handful of
developers to add new packages we also
already and I don't have a slide for
this if you have a binary wheel of a
pure Python package on pipe I you can
install it it just works so go wheels
and they make that easy
all right so that's piyah died I'm going
to check my time okay so now I'm going
to talk about the server know like I
said this is an optional feature but I
think it it turns this from a thing
that's kind of a cool toy and does into
a real professional collaboration tool
so we want to like build a real like
Google Docs like experience where you
just edit and things are saving and you
don't have to care about remembering to
say if like just keep that you know the
thing that everyone knows from Google
Docs we don't care about that stuff make
it easy to share add commenting
collaborative editing forking all these
nice things that Google Docs is sort of
the shorthand way of saying that and a
place for archiving and exporting your
notebooks as well as your data I think
when you have data scientists all
managing their own stuff sometimes it's
a little tricky for collaboration but
whereas if you have a centralized place
to just share and work around that's
basically what the server is going to
handle the server also acts as sort of a
data broker there's many times where in
the browser you can just hit an HTTP URL
and get your data back you have some
data service or whatever that doesn't
always work sometimes there's like an
authentication thing you do need to do
in the way in the middle and the server
will help with those sort of cases and
act like a broker or a connector to
various data sources so now I'm gonna
invite my coworker tee on up here and
maybe you can explain what this is while
I get the demo going sure so in the
former life of the neuro scientists and
I actually specialized in
neurophysiology so this what we have
right here is a portable EEG so this is
connecting over bluetooth it's pretty
cool is no longer the case that you have
to go into a lab get hooked up with
electro in order to have your brainwaves
right so this is pretty cool 200 bucks
is from Muse it's a great company so
every turns out chewed on yeah okay so
we're connecting to the headset using a
technology called web Bluetooth which
lets your web browser communicate over
bluetooth to all kinds of crazy devices
but you can do it blow your brain
through the web we're having the same
issue we had the other day sometimes
this glitch is out and we it doesn't
connect the first time I'm gonna reboot
the reload the page please turn it off
all right gonna restart this worked last
time at least to restart it so haven't
gotten to the bottom of where that's
issue is but ok I'll reconnect won't let
me there we go let's not let you mean
click the button alright one more time
one more time as the charm right so and
to talk about what this notebook is
doing it's taking the Bluetooth data
from the headset bringing it into Python
performing an FFT over there because we
have FFT and numpy and then plotting
that out again using matplotlib so it's
a real like hybrid of all the various
technologies here and what EEG does it
measures the voltage on the scalp so you
can think of this as a multi volt meter
and you basically have a reference and
then you have we have data coming out
your head he's getting noise right now
try not to think too much so we got a
nice some very tough let me see yeah I
can try there you go so you're seeing
the the top four lines on the four EGS
the four detectors on the device so we
have a bottom one as the FFT we have TP
nine we have a f7 f8 TP 10 so these are
the frontal electrodes these are the
ones around the temporal parietal and
what's really cool this is also used for
meditation so one thing that we know
from meditation is that when you are
being very attentive very focused you
have an increase in the alpha-alpha
range which is between 9 to 12 Hertz so
there's oscillations that happen in the
brain and between 9 to 12 Hertz when you
are meditating you see an increase of
power so what you will see in the FFT is
that the values go up when you're
meditating versus when you are talking
or just doing other things where you
don't have a singular focus where is
Dell
cool yeah live demo yeah alright so I
just got two more slides and then I
think we have some time for questions um
alright so part of us coming here we're
Mozilla this is all open-source this
isn't really a sales pitch at all we're
actually a call for contributions we
need experimenters designers programmers
writers bug hunters anyone who's
interested in helping us out find us on
github
that's our github project we are also
having an unconference space at 4:30 in
Belasco way down around the corner and
yeah and there's my email so that's
that's it this is great wonderful work
and really inspiring stuff you mentioned
that on the right now the biggest
performance bottleneck is is doing kind
of native - operations and you also
mentioned that as opposed to some other
libraries isn't there's not any
translation happening have you
considered transpiling easily transpiled
bits of Python into JavaScript or web
assembly so I haven't played with that
at all I mean I have played with the
rice on package and demos and the
thought of rebuilding a numpy that would
work in that environment sort of put me
off and thought this might be a faster
path to all the data science stuff but
you're right there may be some sort of
hybrid approach in the middle there if
like transpiling some of it and getting
it to connect I just I have an
experiment that at all yeah
thank you question you said to you we
couldn't get raw sockets but can we get
web sockets and can we get them today
yes
yes you can get web sockets but you have
to have something that speaks web
sockets at the other end no Mike I
really liked the format of the
jupiter-like plaintext mm-hmm that
doesn't have the output or it's planned
because what you showed was only the
input right yeah so I actually was input
on one side and the output in another
pane we actually in an earlier iteration
of this we were more like Jupiter where
we had inputs and outputs interleaved
and just from the user community within
Mozilla we had the feedback was that
that was for it for a tool that's about
building a rapport that actually got to
be really confusing because a certain
point you're trying to have things be up
here but your text your code is down
here and so it was much easier to just
do it side by side and more like a more
like a console thing and my
understanding is this is what matlab
does this is what our studio our studio
does this too so that's the model we've
we've gone with I mean internally in the
text file is it store everything input
and output or is it separated this isn't
two folds it doesn't store any output in
the in the text file it's just input the
I the premise is that you can always
generate the output because you're
always going to be in a browser
environment yeah good thank you sure
oh yeah um I think this is really cool
uh have you tried using f2c to compile
those bits of Fortran yes and actually
FTC gets us pretty close F T
unfortunately f2 c only supports fortran
77 and there is some more recent fortran
standard stuff in inside pi + r so again
like I think the last commit to F 2 C
was sometime in 2002 or 3 so it's kind
of a static project but it would be
there's there's all kinds of ways we can
hopefully move it forward I think there
was question up here if we still have
time how easy is it for someone to
replicate your demo is it on your laptop
is it
I missed the initial part is it on the
cloud yeah I did everything locally on
my laptop because I always worry about
conference Wi-Fi but many of these demos
are actually already available online
that I died i/o unfortunately it's an
older version of of our thing but you
can just visit it there and hit it with
your browser and and and play with it
yourself yeah so I have two related
questions so the first one is if I have
a command line application how easy is
it to look at a terminal that then you
you can use the command line application
from the second question is say I have a
rich client application based on QT or
whatever mmm how easy is what happens
when you go and try to load those tools
where do they get rendered and what
happens there so with the command line
application I haven't put any effort
into trying to get like standard in and
standard out working the stance so
standard out kind of works if you say
print from Python it prints to the
JavaScript web console right if you open
up the developer tools that's where it
comes in and actually and actually the
default behavior is if you read from
standard in it pops up a little dialog
if you've ever seen JavaScript alert
that really old-school thing pops up a
little dialog where you can type things
so that's what works now not really what
you're talking about but the pieces are
all there to probably build something
like that I just we haven't put any
effort into it my understanding is that
QT has a web assembly port that's being
worked on so if you put it together with
that theoretically you know there's a
big splashy demo of AutoCAD running in
the browser which is like an old old you
know traditional desktop application and
so it can be done it's just how much
effort it is it's hard to say yeah
perhaps a very goofy question but do you
mean like once you have a psychic learn
there would envision some parts of
machine learning production being moved
to the front end using this technology
say recommendation systems or carousel
um I I think it's hard to say so I I
think we're the the sweet spot of this
is like for a notebook where the where
the Python is exposed to the user like
that's where I think this is really
interesting because you have a really
good reason for Python to be there which
is that it's the user interface to what
you're trying to do for things that like
are in production that maybe work in a
different environment this is not going
to be the most efficient way to do that
it might be the most developer efficient
way and so there's that trade-off but
yeah I don't really yeah I don't really
know but it's it's an interesting space
to look at too
a lot of the tooling I guess is written
in rust and then like the transpiler
compiled - who has a web sembly so no
it's it's all like it's the literally
the C Python source code that gets
compiled to web assembly
there's no rust in here yet we'd like to
have some rust support but it's it's
just the upstream projects recompiled
with a few patches to make it all work
they look is there any projects you know
that are looking at targeted at having
being able to compile like python to
Wesen or i guess is this kind of what
it's yeah so this is this is the this is
basically interpreting python in the
traditional way that c python does but
inside the browser Brian is something
that that compiles or converts the
Python to JavaScript so it's a different
approach it it ends up being less like
standard Python and a little less
complete but who knows with more work on
that that might be that might be a
relief viable approach - yeah thank you
it was really incredible Thanks think we
might have time for one more for Fortran
compilers for compiling Fortran there's
something called flaying that composites
LLVM ir which goes through web assembly
have you yeah we've actually been
talking to the flank developers and
they're very receptive in general to
this idea there's a little work that
needs to be done so flang is it uses a
port of LLVM that's a little old so the
web assembly support is not great so we
need to kind of push LLVM from this end
and flank from this end and get them
meet in the right place but the pieces
are there and i it's hard to say how
close it is but the you know we wouldn't
have to start from scratch
yeah probably do one more okay
all right yeah thank you very much
you'll be in a Belasco later